このエピソードがございますけどね
まあこれまた結構皆さんはご存知だと思いますけど
何回もまあこのエピソードはこちらで言った覚えがあります
このお釈迦様の 3番目の弟子ね
名前はマハーカッサパというんです
で なかなか 3番目ですからね
まあ現代まで仏教はね
お釈迦様は涅槃に入られたからね
まあ仏教をちゃんと整理整頓して世界に伝えるようにとしてやったのはマハーカッサパ尊者なんです
で 禅宗でも自分たちの思想の流れで 第1にするのはマハーカッサパ尊者なんです
他の大乗仏教ではあまり仏教とは違う世界だから
あまり知らないみたいですけど
禅宗はどちらかというと仏教なんですね
ブッダの教えを実践する宗派です
で 他の宗派はブッダの教えではないんです
やっているのは ですから
師匠が違いますからね
開祖様が違いますから
同じ宗教というのはあまり学問的じゃないんです
それはそれで置いておいて
禅宗も同じサカムニブッダの教えを実践する宗派でしょうしね
いくつか宗派ありますけど
みんな同じ サカムニブッダの教えをなんとか頑張ろうということで頑張っている
ですから ブッダのサカムニブッダの教えを自分の宗教としている人々の場合は
このやっぱり開祖様というお釈迦様なんですけど
トップの師匠がやっぱりマハーカッサパ尊者なんです
で サーリプッタ尊者 モクレン尊者という 2人がいたんですけど
お釈迦様より先に涅槃に入られたんですね
で お釈迦様はあまりこの組織やらね
もう社会のことやら そういうものにはもうほとんどもう関係ない感じで立ち触らなかったんです
あなた方のことをあなた方は責任を持ってやってくださいということで
いくらかインド人というのは独立がありましたからね
日本ではなかなか成り立ちませんだけど
やっぱりそれはうまくいったみたいんです
それで民主主義でお互い責任を持ってみんな平等に話し合って
自分たちの組織を作って頑張れるようにと
それにお釈迦様が入り込んで何かなんかおっしゃると
それはものすごい独裁的になります
なぜならば ブッダに上の誰もいませんだからね
それをよく知っていて
お釈迦様に言われたことは
絶対的な権限で 命令で
誰にも変えることはできない
だからお釈迦様は関係ない立場でこういうふうにするべきですよという項目やら席割りやら全部決まっておいて
サンガやら弟子仏弟子たちに自分たちで組織を作って頑張れるようにと
そういうことだから カッサパ尊者がやっぱり弟子の一人でしょうし
またもうトップでしょうし
もう 1番目 2番目に涅槃に入られたんだから
仏教はもうちゃんと次の世代に伝えるようにと全て整理整頓してあげたんですね
かなり道徳的な すごい厳しい王様でしたけどね
でお釈迦様と一緒に生活はしなかったんで
すっごい一人で ある洞窟があって
この王舎城というところに
王舎城はそこの高い山っていうのはほとんどないんですけどね
まあそこそこ有名な洞窟があって
この洞窟にずっと生活していたんです
弟子たちはそれほどいたわけじゃないんです
弟子たちがたくさんいたのはサーリプッタ尊者のところで
カッサパ尊者のところはものすごい弟子の数少ない
もうずっと一人で生活して
ある時はこの若い二人がね
出家して弟子になったんですね
この弟子二人の一人がすごいできた人で
出家としてやるべき仕事っていうのは
もう何でもかんでもしっかりやるんです
で 住んでるところはね
もう毎日朝早く起きて掃除しなくちゃいけないし
綺麗にする たとえ森の中に生活したっても
仏弟子たちが住んでるところはものすごいぴったし綺麗にしておかなきゃいけないんです
で 水をちゃんと汲んでおかなくちゃいけないし
まあ便所やらそういうものあったら
これまたぴったしきれいにしておかなくちゃいけないし
そういうのはもう全部弟子たちのもうこれワッタとパーリ語で言うんですね
戒律の一部なんです だから仏教の場合はもう聖職者とかね
それは成り立ちません
もう食いために あるいは立場がないんだから立場を作るために出家するんじゃないんです
大変なこれもうずっとの修行の世界なんです
たとえサティル開いても
そのしきたり 決まり そういうものはすごいたくさんあります
言葉使い方からね 何でもかんでも
で そこで性格悪い連中が入っちゃうと
もうそれはしきたりわかるわけないでしょうしね
とにかく仏教のしきたりっていうのは
釈迦民族の生活習慣なんですよ
ほとんど 目上の人を尊敬することやらね
たった一日でも年上だったらもう順番決まってます
釈迦民族の中で 厳しいんです
それで釈迦民族は全く嘘をつかないみたい
何があっても どんな理由があっても嘘をつかない
しかし 結構強豪 その代わりに
負けない もうめげない
何事にも だからって別に力あったわけじゃないんですよ
本当に小さな国でしたからね
ものすごいインドで もう小さな国で
また山の間で そんな大国ではなかったんです
なのに あのめげないことやら
もうしっかりしていることだから
なかなかまあ国でしたけど
一応コーサラ国に潰れましたし
消えてしまったんです
ですから 弟子たちのお釈迦様が
やっぱり自分が小さい時から習った
王家の人を通してね 習ったしきたり習慣をほとんどそのまま教えているんです
なぜそんなことを言うのか
例えば今一番世界でね
誰でも大事に指導者として考えているとアメリカがありますね
アメリカで何か言ったら
それは世界基準に現代なっちゃうし
アメリカ人がもう何人かが頭が剃っていると
これ世界基準になっちゃってみんな頭剃っちゃうし
だからもうどうしようもないんですけど
[鳥の鳴き声]アメリカで何か変な歌でも流行っちゃうと
もう世界狂ったような感じで
みんな同じことを同じことを真似て
もう最新の最先端にいるんだぞということになるんです
それでまあ それは現代社会のね
まあそうなっていて それでアメリカのしきたりは何なのかというとね
もうあまりこの目上の人とかってあんまり考えてないんですね
誰にでも名前で呼び合うという
これっていうのは私たちにとっては
まあそんなに英語わかるわけないんだけど
やっぱりすごい喋りにくいんですね
アメリカ人と 人をただもうファーストネームで呼ぶっていうのは
これは友達ぐらい同じ年でなかっては
もう我々にとっての我々のしきたり習慣でではできないんです
だから何かそれなりの敬語は使うんです
だから私たちはまあもうまあちょこちょこっと昔ね
学校で英語の単語とかね
習ってもらったことがありますけど
やっぱりミスターとかね
まあ必ずミスターっていうことを使わなくちゃいけないし
できるだけファーストネームじゃなくてサーネームで
喋る で 名前ジョンスミスだからミスタージョンとは言わない
ミスタースミスと言うんですね
これがアメリカ人にとってみれば
ものすごい形式的で もうえらく堅苦しいみたいですね
一番目上の人々は まあ私たちに教えられたのは
Sir という言葉で呼ぶようにと
SIR ね  Sir アメリカではその Sir という単語は聞こえてきません
誰にも使わない 使うとおかしいっていうか
軍隊でだけ使ってるみたいですけどね
それでも若者にはこれに慣れるのは大変なんです
自分のグループの司令やってる人に対してすぐ名前で呼ぶんですけど
これは軍人のしきたりではもう違反だから
ものすごく怒鳴って もう何やそれはと言わない限り
またもう一度繰り返して言わせてもらうんですね
そうって  Sir というセクションを入れて
だからこの習慣というのはそういう風にもう変わるもんなんですけどね
で 今 現代イギリスはどうかわかりませんだけど
だからまあ一応イギリス形式で
我々の国も植民地でしたからね
そういうちゃんと敬語がすごいたくさんありますよ
一つ二つじゃないんです
で 裁判官どう呼ぶのかとかね
王家の人はどう呼ぶのかとかね
で 国賓はどう呼ぶのかとかね
まあそれぞれそれぞれそれぞれの呼び方があるんです
英語で まあ誰も知らないっていうかね
で なんでそういうことを言ったのかというと
やっぱりこの仏教の中にあるしきたり
習慣っていうのは あのいわゆる当時の釈迦族で
みんなの間であったことで
しかし 呼び名だけはもうなんか同志という言葉でお互いに呼んでいたみたい
民主主義国家でしたから
年下の人にでも同志といった言葉でアヤスマントという言葉を使うんですね
お前とかなんとかとかは使いません
お釈迦様はそれだけやめてくださいと
坊さん同士で それをやめてくださいと
目上の人には敬語を使いなさいと
下の人には同志と呼んでもよろしいと
で 目上の人にとっては敬語を使わなくちゃいけないということになっているんです
で それで出家した者は
このどんなカーストの
どんな地方の誰が出家するかわからないし
全くの道徳なんかはね
しきたり習慣なんかは糸かけらもない人もね
まあ領主の息子たちやらね
特に狩人とかね そういう人々にはもう何の道徳も
何の言葉の扱いもないんだから
そういう人でも出家はするんですね
ですから これが教えなくちゃいけないって
みんな同じくならなくちゃいけないって
これしっかりと決めて
戒律の一部として 日常生活の礼儀作法を叩くんですよ
その中に礼儀作法で言ったって
身の回りの仕事をすることね
これとても大事なことで
自分の国でも出家するのはほとんど子供ですからね
子供たちっていうのは遊びたいし甘えてもらいたいだけなんですけど
やっぱり一旦寺に来たらすぐまた仕事をさせるんですね
これやりなさい これやりなさい
あれやりなさいとかね
で それ大人もやってますから
子供たちも何のことなくやって
それでどんどん身についてくるんです
だから生活習慣というのは
出家はほとんど似ていて同じで
何のことなく解けます
民衆とは関係なく それでこのカッサパ尊者のこの弟子二人の一人が
まず早く起きて 全て作業はやって終わって
お経をあげたりとは正直でなかったんだからね
修行する世界でしたからね
今みたいにお勤めとかね
仏像の前に座り込んで
なんとかガチャガチャガチャガチャね
見え張ってやるとかね
俺の方が誰よりも偉そうとか
それはもうなかったんで
仏像さえもなかったんだからね
お釈迦様はいたんだからね
だからごく普通に生活する
朝早く起きてまず瞑想して
それから聞いて学んだからね
聞いて学んだものあったら
それは暗記してもらったりして
それから掃除をして水を汲んでおいて
お偉い長老の下にいるんだからね
長老の身の回りの世話は全部やってあげたりはする
そこで性格的に自我がない人になることは期待しているんですよ
逆に自我でわがままで高慢で俺がしっかりやってるんだぞという気持ちで
道徳やったらやら挨拶やらやると
世界一あれほど嫌なことはないんです
いくら丁寧に挨拶したっても
それ形でやるものじゃないんです
やっぱり気持ち的にちゃんと謙虚にならなきゃダメなんですね
そういうことで この一人の弟子がしっかりそういう全部やっていて
もう一人はかなり偽善で他人やってることは自分がやったように見せる
知らない人はなるほど
この人よく頑張ってるなと思っちゃいますからね
それでマハーカッサパ尊者に
例えば朝顔を洗うために水を用意しておくんですね
一人の弟子が 用意しておいて
その人忙しいんだからね
マハーカッサパ尊者のいるところに
水を入れておいて また次の仕事に行く
で 何もしない弟子がさっさと来て
カッサパ尊者に挨拶して
先生 顔を洗う水を用意してますけどとかね
で 体洗ったりする場合は
もうお湯を沸かせたりして
それで仕事をする弟子がちゃんとお湯沸かしておいて
体洗う場所に全部全部用意して
それとおいて本人は別の仕事に行く
それでこの何もしない人は何もしないで待っていて
用意できたなとわかったら
先生沐浴する時間なんですけど
用意していますけどと言うんです
だから仕事をする弟子にはもう行く暇もないんだとこちら書いてますね
水をちゃんとお湯用意して
座る腰掛けを用意して
まあもう石鹸なかったんで昔はね
あの石鹸の代わりに何か使ったものありまして
この泥を使っていたんですね
特別な泥で それは砂を取って
あの泥のあのヌルヌルしているすごい気持ちいい泥なんですけどね
あの泥でもないんですね
何て言いますか 粘土みたいなものなんですけどね
そういうのはこのボールにして
しょこっと乾いて置いておくんですね
乾いたっても 水が入った途端
もうまたヌルヌルという状態になっちゃうんですね
それを全部もう体に塗って
で これから体洗う もしかすると石鹸よりはすごくいいかもしれません
そういうものは用意して
ある瞬間でこの人サッと走っていって
先生に報告して終わってるんです
そこでこの仕事をするお坊さんが何かもう何か腹が立ったみたいですね
で 仕事をするお坊さんが
やっぱり水やら全部もう沸かして
で 一応沐浴するところにまあまあまあ水を入れると
物やらあるんですけど
まあで もう全部しっかり仕事するんだから
もうしっかりやってると思って
この 2番目の人をサッと走って長老に言ったんですね
尊者 もう用意してますよと
それはまあ長老がこちらに来るんです
来たらこの人はまあ長老の体洗ってあげようかなと思って
まああれ水入れて開けてみるとお湯はないんです
ただ空 それで怒って あいつは何やってるんですか？水も入れてないんでしょうとかね
それで怒鳴るんですね
長老が来ているんではないかとかね
で それでまああの人はまあ後からね
何のことなくお湯を持ってきて
そちらに入れて 長老のあれは用意してあげたんですね
そこでカッサパ尊者が
なるほど このからくりはそうやってやっていたんだと
こいつはね 一人だけちゃんと戒律の行儀を守っていて
それは何もやらないで
ただ長老はこのこの世界ではね
自分がやったことはなら自分でやったと言いますよと
自分でやってないことまでね
自分でやったと言いませんよと言ったんです
そこでこの仕事をしない人はものすごくそれにまたさらに怒ったんですね
そこでこのマハーカッサパ尊者に対してすごく怒って
それぐらいのことでここまで言われる必要ないでしょうと
大したこと言ってないんですけど
怒ってもマハーカッサパ尊者にとことんもういじめてやろうと思ったんですね
次の日は一緒に托鉢に出かけなかったと
怒っても一緒にも行きませんよと
次の日はもう長老が仕事をする弟子と一緒に托鉢に出て
そのまま用事があって別のところへ行ってしまったんです
行ってしまったところで
この人はまた村に行って
後で托鉢に出たんですね
で 長老は別なところに行っていて
そしたら今日は長老はどうなっているんでしょうかと
そしたら長老はお寺にいるんだからと
で ちょっと調子が悪いところ出かけませんと
これは大変だと で どうすればよろしいかと
じゃあこういうこういうものを用意してあげたらいいでしょうかと言って
いろんな食べ物やらいろいろ用意してもらって
自分がそれをもらっていて
それを自分で食べるんです
長老は別なところに行きましたから
そちらで長老はすごい生地一つもらったんですね
信者さんから生地っていうのはものすごく高価ですよ ５ ６
メートルぐらいの生地っていうのは
もう並の値段じゃないんです
で だからそこあって まあこれはもうカッサペ信者に寄付した
お布施した方がね もうあまりにもすごい高価なもので
まあ高価っていうのは
ただ作るのは大変だからね
全部手作りでね 綿からね
糸を作って 糸から織りなくちゃいけないしね
かなり大変時間かかるもの
長老がだいたい自分着ている衣がもう着られないぐらいボロボロになってない限りは
新しい着替えは取らないんですね
長老はいい生地もらったんだから
弟子にあげたんですね
一緒にいた それは君の衣作って使いなさいと
で この仕事をする弟子と一緒に行ったんだからね
その弟子は寺に戻って
これは切って ちゃんと縫って
色をつけて染めて 染めてもったら
ものすごい立派な衣 長老の衣よりも結構立派
で これにもこの人はもうすごく機嫌が悪い
何も仕事をしない人っていうのは
もう何でも自分のことを褒めてほしいんですね
人がやった仕事も自分がやったと思ってほしいし
何かご褒美やらもらうんだったら自分がそれをもらいたいんですね
その代わりに何もしないという
というふうな性格ですよ
一応 これ昔からあまり変わらないと思いますけど
家族の中でも同じことなんですよ
家族の中で何もしない人に限って何でも要求する
褒めてほしいし 新しい服買ってあげなくちゃいけないし
家のこと一生懸命心配している人には何かあげたら腹が立つんです
で 普通の家族の中でも大体そういうことなんですけど
そこで信者の方々はお見舞いに来たんですね
長老がすごい調子が悪いと話を聞いたんだから
そしたらお見舞いに来ていかがでしょうかとかね
いろいろ食事はどうなったんでしょうかとかね
また何かありますかと
送ったもので治りましたかと
それは全然知らない そんなことは
たらもう それでまあ先生の弟子がね
まあ報告したんだから
それで長老が信者さんが帰ってからね
弟子にね あんたやったことは出家はやってはいけないことですと
出家にふさわしくないんだと
人に命令してね これ作ってくださいと
おかゆ作ってくださいとかね
あれ作ってくださいとかね
命令して作ってもらう
食べることは禁止だと
あんたやったことは戒律違反やと
そこでさらに怒ったんですね
昨日は水お湯がなかっただけで私に怒鳴り散かったし
今日は私はもう戒律を犯してもう嘘つきやと言ってるんではないかと
ものすごい怒ったんですね
やってんかったら文殊尊王って言って
それでもう怒ってね あれほど豪華な衣もらって
あれも椅子にあげちゃって
昨日私を怒鳴って 今日私は嘘つきやと言って
戒律破ってると言ったりして
これはもう我慢できんと
思い知らせてやらなくちゃいかんと
火をつけたんですな 長老住んでるところに
火をつけるだけじゃなくて
燃えないところも一応グタグタ破って燃やしたそうですね
こうやって出て行って
もう彼がまあそこそこすごい住みですからね
もう大なる方ですからね
カッサパさんではね まあ死んでしまったみたいですけど
で それでこのお社上からある比丘がね
お釈迦様のところに行ったところでお釈迦様はどこから来たんでしょうかと言ったら
お社上からだったらもうカッサパさんじゃどうですかと
と言ったらもうお元気でいますよと
なかなかお釈迦様に全然会えませんだからね
元気なんですけど 実はこういうこともあったんだと
ある日はと 言ったら この
あの人はね こうやって性格悪いのは今だけじゃないんだと
過去生でもね すごい性格悪かったと
お釈迦様がちょこっとジャータカ物語るようにですね
ジャータカ物語る場合も森の中でこの鳥がいて
まあすごいあの冠が翼じゃなくて
このくちばしの上に冠のようにすごい大きいでっかいものついてる
あると 私たちはコケトウという英語の単語なんですけども
名前の鳥なんですけどね
かなり綺麗ですけどね
くちばしがかなりもうペーンとしてますしね
上なんかとんがっていて
なんか角のように見えるんです
角ではなくて 頭の上に冠みたいな羽ができる鳥いますけど
あのくちばしの上にも出てる種類が
その鳥なんですけど で
巣を作って成婚 そちらに猿も一匹いたんだと
すごい雨 雨が降っているところで
猿はもうもう何も作れませんだからね
で ビシャビシャぬれて
もう何とか葉っぱでなんとか頭を
オランウータンも雨が降ると何か葉っぱを頭につけているんですけど
すごい水が嫌いですよ
オランウータンも 体でっかいし水が嫌いんですけど
雨が降ってくると何か葉っぱを頭につけているんで
体それで覆われちゃいますけど
で こういう風にいて そこでこの鳥がね
何か一言言ったんですよ
鳥が言ったのはね 「あなたはね
人間と同じでしょう」と
しっかりと手足あるでしょうと
人間と同じく使えるでしょうと
なのに なんで屋根を作らないんですかと
全く人間と形も同じで
手足も自由に動かす動かせるし
もう器用し なのにあなたに家がないんだと
これに怒ったんですね
猿は それで猿は鳥が思ったのは 「
あれ こいつに手足があってもおそらくアホでしょう
おそらく」と 手足があっただけではね
仕事はできんと だからおそらく技術も何もできんかもしれませんって
それ言ったんですね ヤーフセッターマヌッセーサーネイパンニャーナヴェッディティ
そこにまあおそらくあなたね
人間と同じくね 手足があるんだけど
まあ知恵がないでしょうね
おそらく 頭が悪いでしょう
鳥から見れば もう手はないし
翼になっているし 足で何もできないしね
全部口でやらなくちゃいけないでしょうに
くちばしで それでも立派な巣を作って
しっかり雨に濡れないようにと
あったかく住んでるんですね
それで猿がすごく私を貶したと
ぶじゅぶせ 怒ってあの鳥のあの巣をね
むちゃくちゃ壊しちまったんです
で それがこのジャータカ物語で
まあまあそれでこのカッサパ長老はね
もう出来の悪い弟子で困ったのは今だけじゃないんだよと
だから愚か者と一緒にいるものじゃないんだよっていうことは
これブッダの言葉ね あの偈に出てくると
この現代のね 方々はすごい高度な学問というかね
ものすごいあの教育制度というかね
教育学というもの 世の中にありますね
だから教え方も別になら学ぶというね
大学までやってね で これは現代時代でね
しかし昔は教育学というものはなかったんです
学校制度とか まあ小学中学もなんでしたっけ
小学小中高とかね 大学制度とか大学院制度とか研究の仕方とかね
データの取り方 研究の仕方
実験の仕方とかね そうやって厳密に論理的に知識を与えるシステムというのはなかったんです
だから今だったらね 学校でもまあもう教師がね
ずっと徹夜して授業を作って
プリントを作って あれやこれやとか調べて調べてデータを取って
で 子供たちに配る 子供たちはそれでマルバツマルバツ入れるだけで大体2 3
分で終わりますけど それで疲れた
今日は宿題がありすぎてとかね
もうどうしようかとかね
すごく困ったりするまで教育システムすごいんです
で 私から見れば5分でマルバツ入れればいいのに
苦しいのは先生の方なんですけどね
それで高いレベルの教育はさせてますけど
昔はそういうシステムというのは何一つもなかったんですよ
しかし 残念なことにね
当時の人間には現代人にないほどすごい知識はあったんです
現代人に信じられないぐらい知識があったんです
もう例えば星のことにしたって
もうきちんと計算してやるんだからね
何の機械もない時代に
インドのね 昔は星の学問がありましたからね
お釈迦様禁止してますけど
勉強するなよと あれは月食
日食だけじゃなくて 惑星同士でそういう
何て言いますか 日食みたいに見えるでしょ
それまでも知ってるんです
で 何年何月何時何分にこれ起こるのかとかね
あれは迷信と絡んでいるんだから
これは人間にとってどんな影響あるのかっていう
これでもうアストロロジーになるんですね
だからアストロロノミーがアストロロジーになるんですね
アストロノミーは学問だからね
星の位置やら計算することだからね
人間に何の役にも立ちませんだけど
まあそれは学問であって
アストロロジーっていうのは占いですからね
だからそういうところまでできていたんだからね
まあなんせね 今の人々はね
昔の消えますてもね それなりの知識がありましたし
それで昔はこの教育方法っていうのは全てこの物語で教えるんです
だから先生たちはある面では大変ですけど
何か教えたいんですけど
何か物語を作らなくちゃいけないんです
生徒たちに何かおとぎ話を
昔々はですねとかね もうこういう人がいて
こういう人がいて おじいさんがいて
おばあさんがいてとか
なんとか話をする だからもう生徒たちはじっとその話を聞くんです
それ終わると何かすごいことを勉強しているんですね
それはユダヤ民族はやってるみたいですね
ものすごい昔から 今もそうだそうです
ユダヤ教会でも毎日曜日集まったらもう説法はない
別に教えというものはもうそういうガチャガチャ型苦しいものはないんで
何か物語を言う で 昔物語を言うか
自分で何か一つ作って言うかと
それすごいヒューマーいっぱいで面白いからくりがいっぱいあって結構面白いんですよ
だからユダヤ人いうのは
自分たちがずっと歴史上生き残ったのはそういうわけだと
何があっても世界の人類みんな死んじゃってもユダヤ人は残りますよと
ですごく頭がよろしいし
無茶ノーベル賞を取ってるし
アインシュタインもユダヤ人でしょうしね
もう時代の思考回転やらね
もう何でもかんでもそちらでしょうしね
アメリカは徹底的に管理しているのはもう純粋なユダヤ人でしょうし
金融関係といえばね 他の人には入るとこはないし
で 性格は悪くないし 行儀作法はしっかりしているし
で あの まあ大体そんなもんなんですけどね
やっぱりあれほど一つの民族としてものすごく仲良く固めてあって
世界中どこにいても同じしきたり習慣で
またものすごい頑張り屋で
またすごい頭が良くて
一流ですね もう何やっても一流トップになるというね
これどうやってやっているのかと
すごい簡単な方法で物語
だから物語文化に住みたい
今私は最近もうかなり本たくさん買いましてね
ユダヤ文化の 調べてはいるんですけど
やっぱり私は一番読みたかったのは昔話なんですけど
なかなかテキストは手に入らなくて
それで一つ学者がまとめたこの大きな本があって
それ注文したんですけど
これまた本がなくて アメリカ誰かがこのセカンハンドのね
あのセカンハンドなんて言いますか
中古あって  1ヶ月間もいたところで
一応もう 3日前に来たんです
でも私はアメリカに一回しか行ったことないんだけど
すごい厚い本がありましてね
ちょこっと見たところでびっくりしたんですよ
この子供たちに教える知恵っていうのは
この人々は冗談じゃないぞと
こんな物語読んで子供たちが大きくなっちゃうと
こいつら怖いと 人類のはもう勝てませんと
びっくりしちゃったんです
それも子供に語っている物語なんですよ
論理の高度さっていうのはすごいんです
ぴしぴしと具体的に物事を考えて結論に至るという
あれは大学で倫理学のやっちゃうと
もうもうもう死にそうに苦しいと思いますけど
子供に言うんですね 物語が
この本の 名前やらあれこれとか
その時も別なことすごい忙しかったんだから
ちょこちょこっと何か見ただけで
あの読む暇なかったんです
もう誰かの本棚にあって
引っ張ってこう見ただけでわかったところだけ
だから名前誰かもとにかくユダヤ人の名前なんかはもう覚えられるものじゃないんだからね
あれ発音もできんし もうすごいへんとか名前ばっかりだからね
で 彼はあまりヒブル語に名前を使う名前訳するんですね
英語に だからゴースタイン
ゴールドバーグ ゴールドっていうのはゴールドメダル
有名な人いるでしょ アメリカで
女の人 まあそういうふうなユダヤ人ですね
ゴールド入ったらまあユダヤ人ほとんど
覚えにくい覚えにくい
だからあの本はいまだに覚えていてほしいなと思ってるんですけどね
だからその人に電話しようかなと今もやっぱりその人に電話して
ほんな名前聞いた方が早いな
今思い出ちゃったんですけど
ピンハツ サーデース ピンハツサーデー
ピンハツサーデー  本の名前よ
ジュビッシュフォークテイル
ジュビッシュ  フォークテイル
そうそう  日本語訳もあります
Amazon で探して
ユダヤの民話って  日本訳はあんた持ってた本でしょ
あれそう小さいんですけど
二巻本なんです 上下二巻
ものすごい安い本です
英語で だからものすごいこの我々の邪悪な物語と比べようもない
ものすごい大量にあります
だから今研究者が集めたと
あちらでもやっぱりこの古い物語だけじゃなくて
時代に合わせてストーリー作るみたい
だから文学の世界でもユダヤ人の方がいつでもトップなんですね
映画の世界やらね もうどの世界でも
もう特にあの笑い芸人だったらまあ九十パーセントぐらいユダヤ人
すごい上手 それでこの笑うことできれば
何の人生でどんな苦しみも乗り越えますよというね
ことと 笑う時は人に笑わないんですね
ユダヤ人の笑い方では
例えば白人をバカにしたりとかはない
一つもない 自分たちをバカにするんです
そこでまたすごいかっこいいんです
で 一つこれ現代物語で一つ今思い出すストーリーなんですけど
ユダヤ人とイスラム人と
あのまたヨーロッパ人がもうどこか船に乗っていたところで遭難しちゃって
人誰もいない島に流されたんだと
で 何もなくたった一本の木があって
その木の下に三人とも座っているんだと
それでさっさとキリスト教の人が木に登って枝を切って十字架を作って
十字架の神様どうか助けてくださいとお祈りするんだと
イスラムの人はもう葉っぱをいっぱい取って
で 敷いて絨毯のことを敷いて
メッカの方を見て アッラー神様にお祈りする
アッラー助けてくださいと
ユダヤ人が木の下でゴロ寝しているんだと
何のことなく寝ているんだと
そしたらお前命心配ないのかと
あの二人に聞いたんですね
大丈夫 私はあのちょこっともう百ドルぐらい借金がありますから
私はどこにいたって見つかりますよ
私はまあ借金したんで
人からお金借りたんだから
私はどこにいたって見つかりますから
心配する事はない だからこれユダヤ人がそこでキリスト教の人を馬鹿にしてない
イスラムの人を馬鹿にしてない
自分たちのことを言ってるんです
だからその だから皆様にはそれで笑い話だけなんですけど
その中でストーリーで勉強する人は
その中で何を勉強するのかということもあるんですよ
ただ笑い話でもないんです
いわゆるそういうところはしっかりするんだというね
お金の貸し借りやらね
あれは明確にしておかなくちゃいけないんだと
論理性の場合はね ある物語があって
あの本にあるかどうか分かりませんだけどね
あるユダヤ人の老人が
このラッバイ系クラスの一番トップの先生クラスのね
人が病気になって入院したんだと
そこでそのコミュニティがね
集めて その人に早く病気治りますようにとかね
そういう何て言うんですか
お見舞いの言葉を送らなくちゃいけないんだから
お互いすごい仲良くだからね
そこであのコミュニティで
何々サンガ長老がね こうなったことで
我々は早くうち治ることはお祈りしなくちゃいけないということで
それでみんな決めて 報告に行ったんだそうです
病院に行って あなたのね
早く病気治ることは コミュニティのメンバーたちが百八十八対十三で通りましたと
いわゆる百八十八人は賛成で
だからだからコミュニティ会議でしょうに
まあもうこの英語でWhatって言うんですね
何々さんの健康祈ることを私はしますと言ったら
誰かセカンドアイセカンドワールドという
英語ではそういうふうにやり取りが
それで賛成の方は反対の方で普通は投票すると
それでそれに賛成百八十八人って
もう反対もやっぱり十何人か
だから もうあれには私も本当に今も思い出すと笑っちゃいます
で 一応世界はね ユダヤ文化系でやってますから
国会ででもね 議員誰かが病気になったり
議員誰かが死んだりすると
国会にそれ出して投票を取るんですよ
その場合は決まって万場一致になるのは当たり前
たとえみんなものすごく腹が立っていた
もう野党の人であろうとも
死んじゃったら国会みんなもう賛成一致で
じゃあ冥福祈りますというね
作って議長がサインして
もう国会はもう万場一致で冥福
何々様の冥福を祈りましたという文書を送るんですよ
これ で そちらで言いたがっているのは
その人が死んでもいいやという
何人か思っていたわけじゃないんです
それはユダヤ人なら読めるんです
私はユダヤ人じゃないんだけど
みんなお互い仲がいいんだから
あの人は死んじゃってもいいやと思っているわけじゃなくて
物事には異論があるんだぞと
万場一致っていうのはありえないんだっていうことなんだよ
言いたがっているのは
たとえ人が病気になって早く治してちょうだいって
それに対して意見だからね
意見だから異論があるんだよという論理なんです
すごいでしょう？だから
世界にあるどんな人間の意見に対しても反論はあり得るんだよと覚えておきなさいということは
この物語で 教えると忘れるわけないんです
また覚えられるでしょ
あまりにもおかしいんだからね
だから勝てようと思ったら勝てませんよ
ユダヤ人にはあの知識には
だから論理であろうか
論争でいう理論であろうか
決して勝てません 私もちょっと挑戦したことがあるんです
土地でああ もうこれ危ない
やめたんです もうもう
すごく当たってくるんですよ
ものすごい それで言いたかったのは
このストーリーで おとぎ話で
昔話で ものすごい難しいことっていうのは言えるんです
だから そういう文化があるんです
インド文化もそういう文化なんです
何かあったら何か物語を言うんです
これがしっかりしているのは
ユダヤの方が歴史的にも古いし
そちらでしょうし で 仏教もその文化で
もう何かあったら物語でいうというね
それでお釈迦様の場合はより中道的で
論理は論理で 真理は真理で
で 数学的に言うものは数学的に言ったりしながら
それどちらにもはめないものはね
性格的なものになってくると
あのね 昔もこんなことありましたよと物語で言うんです
だから本当は楽なんでしょう
物語で難しいことを勉強することをするならばね
日本文化は無理でしょうね
私もちょっとやってみようかなと思ったんですけど
私にとっては色々あのハンディがいっぱいあまりもありすぎちゃってね
物語を語る場合は この語り口っていうのは上手でなきゃダメなんです
なんとか言葉を繋げただけでは
ストーリーとしては成り立たないんですよ
だからちゃんとした生々の生きている言葉を使わなければ違うし
私は皆様と一緒に生活したことは 1 日もないんだから
日常で使う子供たちやら親と子供たちやら使ってるその日本語っていうのはあまりわからないんですね
だからそれ一つあって単語はわからないしね
言いにくいんですけど
ストーリーならさっさと作れます
もう出来事を見たら 見ただけでストーリーを作ることができますけど
言いにくいんです 随分昔
ある子供にね 私は一つ何か物語を言ってくれと言ったんだから
じゃあいいやと言っても
面倒くさい 古い物語を言うのもね
その場で一つ作ったんです
作ったんですけど なかなか終わらなくて
これが恐らく 4ヶ月間ぐらいかかったんですよ
あれは ほぼ毎日ではなかったんですけど
週何回何回 いつも学校終わっても暇があったらまあごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃ走ってくるしね
私が暇があったらもうすぐもうあれ？ストーリーは？と言うんですね
言って小さなそばがそちら座って
それでそれを私は止めたところからまた読んであって
ちょこっと時間たつと私忘れてるんですね
どうなったかと それ繋げないんだから
子供に聞き込んで だからどこまで進んだんですかねとかね
言ったら本人がちゃんとこうなって
こうなって こうなって
こうなって これでこれでこうなったところまで行ったんだよと
と言ったら その瞬間にすぐにこうやって次のエピソードを作ればいいということで
その日で 1つのエピソードを作るんです
まあまあ 言って言えば
このドラえもんの話みたいなもんですけどね
いくらでも作れるんだからね
でも例えばドラえもんっていうね
子供向けのね 物語の漫画あるでしょうし
で 私は物語好きだからね
そういう漫画とかアニメーションとか見ますよ
でもずっと言ってるメッセージはたった 1本ですね
ドラえもんで だから全て時間の無駄なんです
全然子供たちにこのすごい大人になって
このもう IT 世界でビシビシと生きていくために必要なもうまあ競争に負けず
もうしっかりと人格作って生きるようにもう何もないんです
書いてる人もアホでしょうと思いますけどね
ろくでもない人間じゃないかなと
全部道徳的に見れば何もない
一つだけ からくりしたってもダメや
それだけなんですね 結局何もなく何もないんだと
終わり どんな人にそうでしょうね
何かあれあのどうでもなんとかどうもどこでもドアとか何とか出ますけど
終わったら何もない 常でしたっけ
もうなかった方がよかったんじゃないかということになるだけなんです
そればっかり教えたってもね
それでこの場合はこの鳥と猿の話で
もの見事に言ってますよ
猿は人間と同じやと あなたはと
同じでしょうに すっごく指先は自由に使えるでしょうに
人間は家作ってますけどね
あんた次に言うには手があったってダメか
お前バカだからねという話でしょ
手があったとお前アホだからね
初めからね 役に立たねえよと
何言ってますかね 裏で
知恵が大切  いろいろ学びなさいということなんです
生まれつき必要なものはついてるんですよ
で 役に立ちません 頭見たって私の頭より大きいでしょう
皆様の頭は 測ってみたって
まあ百五十グラムぐらいは大きいと思いますよ
脳の重さは でも使ってないんだからね
だから生まれつきついてますよ
全部手も足も脳細胞も何でもかんでもね
これではもう何の役にも立ちません
それはきちっと教育訓練
あれこれと受けてもうしなくちゃいけないんだよ
だったら猿でも何でもできますよと
日本の場合 コピー文句は猿にもできる
なんとかなんとかとかね
使い方は逆なんですけどね
まあしょうがないんですけど
それ一つ教えてやって
それで終わらないんですよ
あのエピソードは いくらなんでも頭の悪い奴らには言うなよと
余計なことをというね
あの鳥が余計なことを言ったんだから
自分の巣を壊したでしょうに
それは大事なアドバイスなんですよ
せっかく皆さん何か言う前に
人にアドバイスする前に
例えばいいことだからといって
相手が間違ってるんだからって
じゃないんです 大事なのは性格なんです
性格悪ければ言った言ったものじゃないんです
言ったら逆にどうなるかわからないというね
だから我々日常生活で生きている場合でも
人間関係という問題で
何でもかんでも言うんじゃないんです
それ失敗するでしょう
かなり で 私たちも人間社会で生きているんだから
言わなくちゃいけないことというのはいくらでもありますよ
子供にいろんなこと言わなくちゃいけないし
会社に行ったら部下にいろんなこと言わなくちゃいけないし
もう言わなくちゃいけないケースというのはいくらでも出てきます
だったら言いなさい あんたは先輩でしょうと
それが気をつけなさいと
そちらにも知恵があるんだよと
それで こちらでは性格悪い人にとってはもうかわいそうでもう捨てられているんです
親切にしない いわゆる社会生活はできないんです
で それ言っちゃうと仏教はもう残酷やと思うでしょうね
違うんです みんなそうやってます
例えば犯罪する人 強盗する人ってどこにいるんですかね
みんな結婚式のなんとかな
何人でしたっけ？呼ぶ？刑務所に年いた経験あるんだから
あれ 結婚式の披露宴の人
何て言いますか？あの人は
誰か夫婦がいるでしょ
仲人 仲人役頼むんですかね
あなた一番忙しいよ 刑務所に年もいたんだからとか
なんで人を殺して服役終わって来ているんだからね
仲人お願いしますと ないでしょ
法律的にはもう服役終わったらもう普通の人間でなんですけど
でもやっぱり いろいろ
日本はどうかわかりませんだけど
アメリカやらね 自分の国でももう選挙に出ることはできない
また仕事もたくさんありますよ
仕事はもうダメ 例えば警察にはいかなる場合でも入れません
で 若者が警察に入ろうと思ってあれだったら
面接やら試験やらそれを全部合格したら
で 面接はパート 2つあります
一つは身の回りをチェックする
兄弟の経歴まで調べるんです
親の歴史はどう？母親はどう？兄弟はどうか？とかね
誰かが何か犯罪を起こしたことあったらもうアウト
それまで調べるんだけど
一番腐ってますけど 警察はね
スリランカでは警察ほど道徳悪くて汚いという人はいませんというぐらい政治家もマシなんですよ
しかし 決まりとしてはもう入るのは難しい
だから世の中では一応道徳を犯したらもう社会の一員にはなれないということは世の中の事実なんです
好き勝手に喧嘩するならば
人を殴ったり 傷害与えるならば放っておくわけにはいきませんでしょうに
慈悲だからみんなに親切にしなくちゃいけないんだからとか
生命は平等だからとか
そんな話はもう成り立ちません
具体的な話になってくると出て行けという風にしなくちゃいけないんです
で だからそういうことは何時間もかけて教えるよりは
あの鳥と猿の話だったらほんの二
三分でしょ ほんの二 三分
そこで物語の読み方 私も記憶にざっと喋ったでしょうに
ものすごい時間かかったでしょうに
忘れちゃうでしょうね
それでも だから 私はどちらかというと
この格好つけてね もう一番先端
先端的な教育方法で学んでもらうよりは
一番原始的な物語で学んだ方がものすごい人格がしっかりすると思いますけど
これは個人的な意見であんまり気にしないでください
そこで あっ 物語読めないんだと分かった一つケースがありまして
あの どなたかインターネットであの経典読んで
経典の一つにこの閻魔様の話があるんですね
これ私から見ればすごい大事な経典なんですけど
で お釈迦様が物語るようにですね
人が死ぬと 死んで閻魔様のところに行くんだと
そしたら閻魔様はもう正義の味方で審判するんだと
そしたら曼珠は あの 何か良いことをしたんですかと
人間でいた時は そんなこと今更聞いたって知りませんでしたと
地獄に来る話はと本人は半ドン取るんです
人間でいいことしておいた
先に言ってもらわないと困りますよと
ただ 私は一つ死者を送りましたけど
会ったことなかったならばと
道徳あります あのね あんたね
人々は生まれるの見たことはないんですかと
いくらでもあります その時思ったことないんで
人は生まれて生活しなくちゃいけないし
どういうふうに生きるべきかとかね
生まれること自体が大変だと
気づかなかったんです
そこはちょっと気づかなかったねとか
じゃあダメよと 私は番目の使者も送ったんだけど
あんたその番目の使者にあって
なんで道徳学ばなかったんですかと
会ったことがないんだよと怒るんですね
この人が あのね 病気な人を見たことないのかと
いっぱい送ってあったんだと
この天使と呼んで天使が
見たことはあります それで
あんた思ったことない人っていうのは
誰でも病にかかるんだと
だから道徳をしなくちゃいけないんだと
善行為しなくちゃいけない
気づかなかったと 気づかなかった
では 私は番目の天使も送ったんですけど
三番目の天使は老いること
老人たち すっごい体ボロボロで
杖でもってやっと生きてる老人たちを見たことはないかと
見たことあるんだけど
あんたその時気づかなかったと
道徳を守らなくちゃあかんと
善行為しなくちゃいけないんだと
人生は永遠じゃないんだと
私はそこだけじゃない 四番目の天使も送ってやったんだよと
これは使者なんですね
いわゆる死んでる人々
死体ですね いくらでも死体見たことはあるんですけど
この人は自分も死ぬんだっていうことを思わなかったんです
それで閻魔様がまあしょうがない
私にはどうすることも助けることできませんよと
私は審判官として精一杯頑張りました
あなたを地獄に落とさないようにと
ですから 自分の行為は自分で受けるしかないんだということで
閻魔様がそういう悲しい顔で
あの 横を見るんだそうです
だから仏教だからすごく一切気をつけるんです
汝はなんとかなんとか地獄に任命する
それはないんです ただ悲しい
横に もうしょうがない
助けられませんね この人はと
それで本人が自分の業にふさわしい地獄に落ちると言うエピソードなんですよ
だから 業によって人は地獄に落ちるのは自動的でオートで
審判ないんです それ仏教学知ってる人は誰でも知ってます
行為の結果だから 個人はいない
初めから 審判ない なのにあのストーリーを入れているんでしょうに
で そこでこのエピソードをどう読めばよろしいでしょうかと
このまま閻魔さんがいると信じてもよろしいでしょうかと
あれこれは質問があったんですね
だから あるスリランカ人が質問したら
ものすごい恥なんですけど
お前人間かという思いになりますけど
やっぱりそれで私は あ
なるほど これ物語は読めないんだと
なんかぐちゃぐちゃぐちゃぐちゃ
これだからこうではないか
あれだからこうではないかという
すごい浅い知識でぐちゃぐちゃぐちゃぐちゃ妄想を並べかけて何か言わなくちゃいけない
簡単じゃない これ智慧がないってことなんです
簡単単純じゃないってことは
智慧がゼロってことなんです
三時間も語らなきゃわからないんだと
一分でわかるのにね 物語映画
私はあそこと返事書いたんですけどね
まあ私達にとってはすごいかっこいい物語ですけどと
あれで生老病死の話をしているというか
生老病死を見て 何て言いますか
恐れを感じなさいよと
怠けるなよと ふざけるなよと
責任を持って生きてみなさいよということを言うと
あまり面白くないでしょうに
閻魔さんがこうするんだぞと言ったところでわかりやすいんですけど
しかし それは仏教の世界の話で
日本になってくると 嘘をついたら閻魔さんが舌を抜かれる
閻魔さんに舌抜かれるそうとか
あれはストーリーでもエピソードでも道徳でも何でもないんです
恐ろしいだけ だから嘘をつくなよという話にはなかなかなりたじゃないんですよ
優しさが無いんです 嘘をついたら針千本とかなんとかとか
だからそういうのはまあエピソードとして使ってまた使ってなくて
ただことわざみたいな感じで使っているだけで
そういうことで何が言いたいかというと
このジャータカ物語やらいろんなところでもストーリー
ストーリー ストーリー
ストーリーいっぱい出ます
だからストーリーだから
まあ鳥は喋るは 猿が喋るは
鹿が喋るは 皆様それですごく困るでしょ
私は困りません 時々鹿が言って
あの菓子のブラフマダト様に説法までする
鹿 あ これおかしい これは誰？これは仏教じゃないでしょ
これはもう仏教じゃないでしょとかね
偉そうなことで ががが
なんとか学識被っちゃって
本当は私はものすごく笑ってますけどね
こんな頭悪くてね よく生きていられるんだと
そんなのはどうでもいいでしょうに
ある日本の方がね そういうこと言ってね
その人真面目に信じてます
そのまんま 公務員の人でしたけどね
私はある物語言いながら
このキャラクターからかっちゃったんです
これはもうこういうこと言いたくてね
これっていうのはおかしいのはもうあまりにもおかしすぎやと
このストーリーはとかね
いわゆる時々ストーリー作るんだけど
どこかであの この 何と言いますか
ドラマがつなげなくなっちゃうんですよ
つなげなくなっちゃうと
カンダタス帝釈天か あの地の神か
何か神霊が出てきてつなげてくれるんです
[笑い]それがないともうとんでもないことになるんですよ
だから必ず必要なんです
その人は私はやっぱりもう神に宿っている神霊がいると思ってますよ
まあちょっといい加減にしてくれませんかと
なんであんたはね 仏教の坊主なのにそういうものを否定するんでしょうかとかね
私はそれを否定するんじゃなくて
このストーリーのストーリー読めないところがね
もうあまりにも無知で
で その瞬間にこの人は仏教では成長しませんと
もうまた何千万回でも人間で生まれ変わって修行してこないと
それはダメだと 本当にすごい知識人ですけどね
俗世間で 日本の基準でいえばすごい立派な知識人なんですけど
仏教は無理 後でヒンドゥー教に行ったみたいんですけど
何でも信じればいいんだから
そのまま 大変ですよ はい
あのそれっていうのは別に文化ですからね
1日にして直ることはできませんだけど
あの まあせっかく仏教を学ぶんだからね
あの日本文化ではないんだから
あの ちょっと違う文化の世界にも入り込んだ方がね
私はもうどんな文化にでも精神的に入り込んで勉強します
だからユダヤ人の文学読む場合は
もうしっかりその世界に入り込んで読むんだから
裏の裏でも読めるし 逆に悪い欠点も見える
すごい汚いところも何のことなく見える
多分 異文化 他人の文化っていうのは気持ち悪いって感じで見るのは良くないんですよ
それで頭が悪くなるだけ
人間っていろんな知識ね
地球上でね いろんな場所でいろんな知識持っている
それから時代的にもいろんな時代でいろんな知識があったしね
全てこの文化の中に隠れているんですね
だから文化システムを理解できれば
なんとかなんとか理解できるという風になっちゃいますけどね
まあだからストーリーでストーリーを読めるならばね
すごい簡単に難しいこと
いわゆる授業で語っても語っても語りきれないものは
ストーリー一つで全部言えちゃうという
だからジャータカ物語ではもう神に宿っている神霊が来る
帝釈天が来る まあいろいろもう鬼もいる
でなきゃストーリー成り立たないんです
言いたいことを言えなくなっちゃうんです
もう動物はみんな平気で
喋る 喋ってもものすごい超一流の詩人にも作るのは難しい歌で喋るんだだからね
また 偈 こちらでも鳥はパーリ語で偈で喋ってますよ
私はちょっと苦労してパーリ語は現代語にしちゃったんだからね
偈っていうのは解読難しいしね
そういう頭が悪い鳥もまた同じ偈で喋ってますからね
それで現代人がね 猿はもともと頭が悪いんだから
どうやって偈で喋ったんでしょうか
これは嘘でしょうとかね
それもパーですね はい
それでは今日の偈で言っていることは
やっぱりこの人間は道徳的に優れている人なら一緒に生活した方がよろしいし
あるいは道徳的に同じレベルならまた一緒にするしかないし
道徳と智慧ですね この場合
道徳よりは智慧なんですね
智慧がないんだったら
もうとにかく逃げろと
逃げて一人で生活しなさいと
そこで昔から決まりがあって
注釈書で言ってますけど
おそらく経典にあるかどうか分かりませんだけど
道徳智慧がない人々とは
セーヴィタッボ 付き合ってはいけない
バジタッボ もう話あってはいけない
パイリパーッサッボ 一緒に生活してはいけないと
はっきり言ってダメと
やめます やめなさいと
しかしアンニャッタ 一応除いてはというね
例外はアンニャッタ アヌカンパーエ
哀れむならばね 相手のこと
アンニャッタ アヌッダターエ
相手のことを本当にもう心配で
もうどうしようもない
放っておけない気持ちだったら
そこは例外で 別に仲良くしましょうって意味じゃないんで
その場合 もう心配だから
まあいいよということぐらいの話で
それはOKなんです 理由は
そうやってね この愚か者はね
私のそばにいると もしかすると道徳的な立派な人間になるでしょうと
だからまあ生かしてやりますという感じではいいんです
それ以外はダメということなんです
まあそこら辺でいいでしょうね
まあ時間も 何時までやりますかね
今日は  一応四時半 あと十五分ぐらい
というわけで 十五分休憩
遊んでください  [笑い]